الأرض على طول الساحل الشرقي
لباتاغونيا قاحلة ،
لكن
البحر غني
بالحياة ، تخترق جبال الأنديز
الهواء الرطب المتدفق من
المحيط الهادئ ،
مما يخلق ثامن أكبر صحراء
في العالم ،
ولكن قبالة الساحل الأطلسي
، يمتزج تيار جنوبي بارد مع تيار
برازيلي أكثر دفئًا.
توفير الظروف المثالية
للحياة البحرية
على اليابسة
، وتطل مجموعة برية من الشواطئ المهجورة من النتوءات الصخرية والمنحدرات الشاهقة
على أحد أهم
المحميات البحرية على هذا الكوكب.
هذه المجموعة المكونة من عشرة أفراد هي مجموعة متماسكة
ستبقى معًا طوال حياتها
[تصفيق
] زعيم هذه العائلة
هو الجدة العجوز الحكيمة
المعروفة باسم ماغا ،
إنها مد وجزر ، وتقود الأم البالغة من العمر 40 عامًا
عائلتها نحو الشاطئ الذي
تستهدفهم
الفقمة المطمئنة  وجراء أسد البحر
ولكن كيفية الوصول إليهم على
الشاطئ ، أتقنت العائلة
طريقة بارعة للصيد  هنا
أولاً يسبحون جانبيًا لإخفاء
زعانفهم الظهرية المنبهة
، وليس لدى الفقمة أي فكرة عن أن هؤلاء
القتلة الذين يبلغ وزنهم ستة أطنان قريبون جدًا ،
ثم يقوم الأوركا بعمل شيء
غير عادي يغطونه بأنفسهم ،
إنها تقنية رائعة ،
الشواطئ هي فخاخ موت للحيتان
والدلافين
، من السهل جدًا القيام بذلك  تقطعت بهم السبل
ولكن ليس لهذه العائلة
تعلموا كيفية المناورة بخبرة
مرة أخرى في
البحر وجرابها هي واحدة من عائلتين فقط من
الأوركا في العالم معروفين بإنجاز
هذا العمل الفذ الخطير